التعليم قضيه معاناه للعديد من الدول
الاسلاميه الامر الذي دفع رابطه العالم
الاسلامي لتطوير العمليه التعليميه في 29
دوله تستهدف برامج الرابطه اكثر من نصف
مليون طالب
عشرات المبادرات والبرامج التعليميه في
دول مختلفه ومئات الالاف من الطلاب الذين
استفادوا منها بدءا من المراحل المبكره
وحتى العليا وفي كافه التخصصات العلميه
جميعها ضمن برامج الرعايه التعليميه التي
تعمل عليها رابطه العالم الاسلامي
للمساهمه في بناء اجيال متعلمه في اشد
المجتمعات فقرا ووسط اقل امكانيات التعليم
لاحداث نقلات في حيات هؤلاء الطلاب
وتسليحهم بالعلم والمعرفه كما ان جهود
الرابطه لا تقتصر فقط على الطلاب
والطالبات بل تعمل عبر برامجها على تاهيل
المعلمين والمعلمات في هذه المجتمعات
لتحقيق استدامه تعليميه فخلال الفتره من
العام 2016 وحتى نهايه 2022
اقترب عدد الطلاب والطالبات الذين
استفادوا من فرص التعليم التي توفرها
الرابطه من 500 وسبعين الف طالب اضافه الى
تاهيل
معلم في اكثر من 29 دوله كما عملت الرابطه
طوال هذه الاعوام على تقديم منح دراسيه
تجاوز عددها سبعه عشره منحه استفاد منها
اكثر من 360 الف طالب فيما قدمت 10 اعانات
دراسيه استفاد منها نحو 140 الف طالب وبين
المنح والاعانات التعليميه للطلاب في دول
عده عملت الرابطه ايضا على دعم ميزانيات
مجمعات ومعاهد وكليات تعليميه في دول عده
منها مجمع دار الحكمه في السنغال وكليه
الملك فيصل في تشاد وغيرها للمساهمه في
استمراريه العمليه التعليميه وتطوير مرافق
هذه المنشات